[Music]
i'm an olympic athlete
and i've followed a plant-based diet for
the last six years of my life
i don't eat meat and i don't eat eggs or
dairy
but it hasn't always been this way when
i first started competing
meat was a big part of my life
i competed as a lightweight rower in a
four-person boat
and i had to weigh 150 pounds just two
hours
before a mile and a half sprint
to give you some perspective as to how
much weight this is
i normally weighed 170 to 180 pounds
and i'm six feet two inches tall
so i had to lose anywhere from 20 to 30
pounds
before a rowing race
food and dieting were a big part of my
life then
and it still is today i want to talk to
you today about how i made food
a competitive advantage in my life and
how i could be in yours too
i hope to convince you that eating more
fruits and vegetables
and less meat will not only help you
grow faster
if that's what you're into but to think
quicker
to have more energy and most importantly
to live a longer
and healthier life
preparation for weigh-in started months
ahead of time
but the really intense part was the week
of racing
on a monday before friday race i started
weighing all my food with a little tiny
scale
three days before racing i'd drastically
reduce all salts and fibers from my diet
with six hours to go before the weigh-in
i stopped eating
and drinking completely finally with two
hours to go
i'd sweat in a hot bathtub
and weigh myself every 10 to 15 minutes
to make sure i didn't overdo it it was
an intense experience
that i don't recommend for anyone it
even sounds kind of crazy
saying out loud now
although making weight was important
leading up to race day
maintaining a healthy weight was an even
bigger struggle
while i was training i had to
consume an average of six to eight
thousand calories a day
just to make sure that i didn't lose any
weight while training
on a typical day before i stopped eating
meat
i would have five eggs for breakfast
a couple of sausages and greek yogurt
for lunch i'd have two giant hamburgers
with some bacon
and for dinner i'd have a t-bone steak
with about a pound of
rice and beans meat
was an important way to maintain my
weight
and to help me recover from all the
training that i did
or so i thought
in 2015 i failed to make the national
team
because of over training and because of
not recovering quickly enough
i was devastated i had been training
for the last 15 years to make the
olympics
i trained four to six hours a day seven
days a week
but the rest of the time i spent
thinking of how to get better at rowing
whether that was stretching watching
video
or eating but it wasn't happening
i wasn't getting better i was stuck
and i felt powerless
not making the team in 2015 made me
question everything about my approach to
training
including my approach to eating
i learned that food was not just a box
to be checked in my daily routine
but a tool that i could use as a
competitive advantage
the first lesson i learned in 2015 was
that food can make my life
a lot better
there's a new field in biotechnology
called inflammation and it theorizes
that
inflammation in the cells is what causes
most chronic heart disease
and chronic disease and what leads to a
shorter life expectancy
billions of dollars are spent a year on
drugs to reduce inflammation
in the cells but we don't have to wait
for these miracle drugs
fruits and vegetables already do this
a recent harvard public health study
found
that consuming five servings of fruits
and vegetables a day
can reduce your chances of chronic heart
disease and stroke
by 20
to put this number into perspective 20
percent
is comparable to the reduction that a
smoker gets
after 10 years of quitting smoking
the best part about the study is that
each additional
serving of fruits and vegetables that
you consume can reduce your chances of
chronic heart disease and stroke
by an additional four percent
to all the business school students out
there i can't think
of a better return on investment you can
literally
eat your way to better health
the second thing i learned in 2015 was
that food can make my life worse
remember all those t-bone steaks and
hamburgers that i was eating
each meal was making my blood more
viscous
it was making it harder for me to
recover from training
and for my heart to work during hard
workouts
think about the last big thanksgiving
meal that you had
or your trip to your favorite barbecue
joint
how did you feel i usually feel
tired and sleepy
over time this means plaque in your
arteries
it means a heart that can't work as well
for as long
the third thing i learned in 2015 was
that maintaining a good diet is hard
i don't need a scientific paper to tell
me that bacon tastes better than
broccoli
i know that i love bacon it's delicious
so how did i overcome this crave
i reduced the number of decisions that i
had to make
i prepared my meals on sundays for the
week and i ordered vegetarian pre-made
meals for the rest of the time
over time i didn't have any meat eggs or
dairy in my refrigerator
and i had no choice but to eat
what i had already planned
the second thing i learned to
maintaining a healthy diet
was to draw distinctions like i don't
eat red meat
or i don't eat dairy rather than picking
and choosing for every meal
the reason for this is again you narrow
your decisions
and you use less willpower over time
so the diet becomes more effective
and sustainable
because i don't eat meat some people
will call me
a vegetarian or a vegan but that's not
what i'm about
i don't want to tie my choices to a
better health to a certain identity
i think it's more important than that
i want to encourage you to be conscious
of the food choices that you make
and to use data to back up those
decisions
because whether we want to think about
them or not our food choices
are some of the most important decisions
that we'll make in life
thank you
you